* Musik: Ben E.King "Stand By Me" *
# Dadadam, tsch, dadadam, tsch
# Dadadam, tsch, dadadam.
# Wenn du gerne kochst,
# Frisches Essen magst,
# Doch am liebsten ohne Chemie.
# Ist das schlecht formuliert,
oh, so schlecht formuliert.
# Denn chemiefrei,
Honey, das ist Essen nie.
# Denn, Darling, alles ist Chemie.
# Alles ist Chemie.
# Oh, alles ist Chemie.
# Chia Seeds, reines Kokosöl,
# Und Naturseife.
# Alles chemische Verbindungen,
weißt du nicht?
# Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst,
# Wenn du sagst, du hasst Chemie.
# Aber ohne,
ohne sie gäb's dich nicht.
# Denn, Darling, alles ist Chemie.
# Alles ist Chemie.
# Oh, alles ist Chemie.
Selbst die Naturkräuter-Zahnpasta
ohne Fuoride ist Chemie.
Alles besteht aus Molekülen.
Es gibt keine unchemischen
Verbindungen auf dieser Welt.
Deswegen sag nicht so Sachen wie:
Ich mag das aber lieber ohne Chemie,
denn sowas gibt es nicht.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Freunde der Sonne, jetzt im Ernst.
Warum ist alles Gute und Gesunde
bio und natürlich
und alles Giftige Chemie?
Alles ist Chemie.
Die Natur
ist die beste Chemikerin ever.
Wenn ihr das genauso seht,
teilt dieses Video.
Kennt ihr nicht auch so Leute,
die lieber auf Chemie verzichten?
Wenn ja,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bleibt sicher